[Music]
let us take a sightseeing tour a day and
enwee i went from town to town around
france looking for a place how can we
find everything in our movie in this
town transform things but use what's
there and never leave
[Music]
the french dispatch is a portmanteau
it's a kind of omnibus film a collection
of short stories set in a fictional
french city only blase the city is on we
the city isn't paris you know it's sort
of an imagine or an amalgamated version
of different aspects of old paris so you
can say it's france but it's a poetic
france it's created and has elements
from the past or from fiction we're
working in ongolam which is a beautiful
classical town it's quintessentially
french and it's architecturally it's
beautiful it felt like it could be a
period setting quite easily it had
levels there's something just
immediately gripping about a town with
staircases and
sloped roads and all these things on we
rises suddenly on a monday
when i first read this script it was
clear to me that every sentence as i
read the first 30 pages was an entirely
new set and
i immediately spoke to him and said how
how how do we do that well i mean it
started with a
substantial panic you know um and a
realization that that's exactly what
this was that each shot was really
defining a new set
i like how ruthless you are
it's part of your beauty i think the
kidnappers lair and we were building a
whole new building but only building on
kind of a mountain
in the middle of the city west has kind
of a great
history of finding
alternate studio spaces the city of
angulam became our sort of back lot we
took over this factory and that became a
de facto like film studio in the center
of town had a bunch of different factory
bays and we sort of took them over and
they were our different stages and then
we also had all of our workshops there
all of our storage there and it became a
studio i mean it really became an actual
film studio totally from scratch
without even electricity when we walked
in the door
how'd you get out there all the city of
the town was working with wes the people
of angulam there's well over a thousand
residents of angulam who are in the
movie so they became kind of our
partners we have an animated sequence in
there which was all animated in angular
with people who live there and study
there this movie is obviously a tribute
to france because all the visual
references they're like a
real france but they've been a bit
twisted because they went through west's
brain it's all from research even though
it's a kind of confection it's sort of
invented stuff and the fantasy element
to it is basically all from research and
how do we shape the research into our
story whatever you're doing that you
want to do it and then try to give it as
much authenticity as you can
what is this world what fast-paced
detailed symmetrical you know wonderland
in this guy's head are we all being
brought on ship for to cross seas with
him as our captain it reminded me a
little bit of a pop-up magazine turned
into film the look of the film the
photography the art direction the
attention to detail of the prop the
wardrobe the choreography between the
acting and the camera it's just very
unique it's just very wes anderson he
takes it to another level
[Music]
[Music]
you